salut c'est jimmy et aujourd'hui je
propose une belle rencontre avec un
jeune couple de martiniquais ils ont
tous quitté tout laisser tomber pour
partir vivre à bali avec en tête un
projet il s'appelle gilles et awa ly et
on les découvre tout de suite sur la
première
[Musique]
locaux a dit salut gilles on est ravi de
vous rencontrer merci de nous faire
voyager un petit peu aujourd'hui vous
nous emmenez attali c'est ça alors vous
y êtes depuis trois mois à peu près on
va parler de vous et de votre parcours
parce que vous êtes de véritables
globe-trotter alors là vous êtes à bali
mais avant vous avez fait le plein de
choses ça a commencé quand cette
aventure en ce road trip ce tour du
monde
démissionnez projet justement est comme
ça c'est une activité essentiellement
sur internet
[Musique]
est ce que vous vous rendez compte que
vous fait rêver tout le monde on rêve
tous de ça de pouvoir un jour tout
quitter de partir je vais pas dire en
vacances parce que vous avez quand même
un projet professionnel derrière tout ça
mais de partir de visiter des pays c'est
quand même un petit peu des vacances
aussi d'aller au gré des envies et de
visiter le monde rend plus à l'est dans
des destinations excusez moi qui sont
quand même magnifique bangkok la
thaïlande bali ya pire quand même hein
[Musique]
c'est juste possible
c'est quoi exactement cette activité que
vous pouvez développer sur internet tout
en voyageant à l'appel griffith et les
coachs sportifs suisses
[Musique]
les antillais spécifiquement lexique
physique glace
le conseil est sur cette visite pour les
analyser du coup à la perte de poids
[Musique]
ces trois visites aux objectifs
d'accord on était entier elle n'a pas
trouvé la culture ça c'est le plus dur
pour nous on veut bien perdre les kilos
se faire des muscles mais il faut quand
même que notre alimentation soit pas
trop restrictive et c'est ce que vous
propose est justement en plus j'imagine
que vous le faites dans des lieux qui
sont magnifiques vous utilisez justement
vos images de voyage voyage les lieux
sur lesquels vous êtes et les endroits
où vous voyagez on a choisi l'asie
ce sont des paysages et une culture qui
est vachement proche de la culture à
thiès on retrouve ici continuer à
travailler après 60 des images on disait
tout à l'heure et on avait déjà discuté
avec effectivement des d'autres
martiniquais qui vivaient en asie et
notamment à bali de cette proximité au
niveau de l'alimentation dans les choses
qu'on retrouve des mets comme j'imagine
les teens 1 par exemple on doit on doit
sûrement les retrouver il ya beaucoup de
choses au niveau de l'alimentation qui
sont peut-être cuisiner différemment
mais beaucoup de nos produits et de
matières premières qu on retrouve aussi
là bas et qui existe chez nous et je
suis
mais nous nous a commencé tout juste la
saison des mangues et c'est vrai que ça
dure pas assez longtemps alors que là
bas toute l'année il ya des manques bon
bah c'est génial ça doit en plus vous
inspirer toute cette richesse parce que
ce sont des pays en plus qui sont
réputés pour la qualité de leur
nourriture pour les mets qui le propose
alors il propose en plus des bonnes
choses visuellement et est bonne mais en
plus des choses qui sont assez proches
de la nature tout ce qui est une fille
et tout ça on appelle ça comme ça tout
sous ce qui est ce un bon pour le corps
bon ça va être génial d'être d'être là
bas pour développer justement cette
activité là on m'a très bien prochaine
destination alors ce sera quoi une fois
que vous serez en mesure de voyager à
nouveau avait déjà réfléchi à vous
partirez et ses 2
la symbolique bon en tout cas on était
ravie de faire votre connaissance de
découvrir aussi votre projet qu'on va
aller regarder sur internet tout à
l'heure merci à tous les deux à wall-e
et gilles plein de bonnes choses pour
votre projet et puis encore plein
d'image plein de voyage pour vous c'est
ce qu'on vous souhaite en tout cas
à très vite merci à tous les deux le
bail
merci de nous avoir suivis s'était
confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs on se
retrouve très vite sur la première
[Musique]